Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Let's get inspired by Pee, Light, Meat, Snack.
The sound of running water may make you want
to pee because of a conditioned association
with running water and going to the bathroom.
Not just with the sound of peeing itself but
the flush of the toilet and washing your hands
- and it might not just be sounds - placing
images of waterfalls above urinals has proven
effective in helping shy bladders.
The standard red meaning stop and green meaning
go on traffic lights comes directly from railroad
signals.
Although green initially meant caution and
white meant go.
That system changed because of an incident
in which a red lens fell out making a red
light look like a white light and causing
a terrible crash.
These colors go back further to industrial
equipment featuring red light for stop and
green while it was running - but red has been
thought of as a danger signal for thousands
of year because it's the color of blood.
People often describe exotic meat like snake,
frog, and alligator as all tasting like chicken
possibly due to evolution.
Chicken and birds in general are widely believed
to be direct descendants of dinosaurs, sharing
a common meaty ancestor with modern snakes,
lizards and turtles called diapsids.
Chicken also has a bland taste because of
a lack of fat and the type of muscle is fast
fiber allowing these chicken-tasting animals
to make short fast movements.
Eating popcorn at the movie theater is commonplace
because during The Great Depression in the
U.S. movie theater owners needed a new way
to make money.
They added snack sales like the cheaply available
popcorn to supplement lower attendance and
ultimately stay in business.
Roaming popcorn vendors gained popularity
in 1885 and they often setup near crowds like
outside of a movie theater.
So minus the "ight" slap in an "and" minus
the "m" and what we're left with is a peel
and eat snack.
Such as the orange.
A citrus fruit which was named orange two
hundred years before the color orange was
named orange.
Before that linguists believe that people
referred to this color simply as yellow-red.
And as always - thanks for watching.